from the company they went bankrupt in
the 90s and sold off the rights to its
most popular characters comes a film
based on the equivalent of leftover
scrap metal
proving that Marvel can build a
franchise around just about anybody
except the Hulk Iron Man experienced the
massive success that bar will turned
into a formula for printing money where
you take a half Irgun B list superhero
cast an unknown or half-forgotten b-list
actor have him fight a generic villain
that will only last one movie fall in
love with a generically strong female
character make a ton of quips talk a
bunch of science destroy some public
property
cram Stan Lee in there somewhere have a
Blue Beam shoot up in the sky set up an
Avengers movie and force the audience to
sit through 500 visual effects guys
names just to catch a few extra seconds
I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative hey if it ain't broke
don't fix it
mr. stark you've become part of a bigger
universe you grew up loving Batman
spider-man and Superman now get ready
for a hero that makes them look like
huge nerds by comparison and meet Tony
Stark a hard-partying Robert Downey jr.
--is-- weapons designer who's the
perfect match between actor and role
that allowed him to spend the next 7
years making a fortune by pretending to
look at a screen pretending to play with
some Holograms doing a little voiceover
keep going and basically act like
himself until someone says cut nice work
if you can get it cheer for a hero whose
power is his intelligence not some
magical hammer as Tony craps out new
technology the way you and I crap our
breakfast like this weapon that's used
against it these weapons that are used
against him a lot of my weapons this
weapon that's used against him
this one right this weapon that's used
against in Tony Stark was able to build
this in a cave this miracle technology
that becomes a weapon that's used
against him and of course
Ultron seriously Tony just do the world
of solid stop working world of weapons
best whatever so we visit the marble
masterpiece that started it all without
which there would be no Marvel Cinematic
Universe no Avengers no guardians no
Winter Soldier leaving Hollywood in the
terrifying position of having to develop
something original starring Bruce Wayne
miss money pair of a die of a Terrence
how hard could it have been to take a
pay cut for the sequels obligatory scan
EO and the Iron Giant Marvel man wow
that's got to be the only time someone
has ever looked cool riding a Segway be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies are you
headed to Comic Con we'll be there all
week doing special coverage and a live
episode of movie fights at our first
ever comic-con panel click the link
below to find out where we'll be so you
can come say hi and tell them epic voice
Matt sent you I am a booty but face
nutty fudge kittens do you want ants
because that's how you get ads your
clothes give them to me now sometimes I
think about Steve Buscemi in a bathtub
my mind is like a well oiled eagle